>> The Comedy Central Roast
of Justin Bieber
with your host master
not Daniel Tosh
and not starring Daniel Tosh,
not Daniel Tosh,
not Daniel Dwight Tosh.
Daniel Tosh is not going to
be there.
Daniel Tosh will not
be roasting.
And finally, not Daniel Tosh.
>> Awkward.
As you know, I have been begging
Comedy Central for years
to let me appear on one of
their roasts and
they never say yes.
It's like
I'm being blackballed.
I even prepared a couple jokes
for Bieber.
What a waste of time.
Would you guys like to
hear them?
Oh, good!
I hear Justin Bieber is a bit of
a playboy, but I like him
just for his articles.
Too soft?
Okay.
Justin thinks he's black.
But if he was black,
he wouldn't have such a small
weenie.
Justin is the only guy lucky
enough to bang Selena Gomez
on the right side of her
quinceañera.
Justin, it's great that you're
trying to clean up your image.
I think I speak for all of us
when I say you should start by
taking a nice long bath
at Bobby Brown's house.
Justin was discovered as a kid
by Usher, which is crazy
because normally when Usher
discovers a kid, they're at the
bottom of his pool.
Oh, well.
Too bad no one will ever get to
hear these jokes.
But a roast isn't just about
mocking desperate celebrities.
It's about being able to turn
the other cheek while
they hurl hate speech
back at you.
That's why I invited the
meanest, cruelest, most immature
bullies I know, my Twitter
followers, to give me the
roasting of a lifetime.
And who better to be the
roastmaster and read
your snarky tweets than my
seasonal next door neighbor,
the Canadian curmudgeon himself,
Old Lee.
Go ahead. Let her rip.
>> "Tosh.0?
More like Tosh point stop
[bleep] dicks
and being an overrated pussy."
>> That's big talk for a guy
who hasn't had a boner
since the '80s.
>> What?
I didn't write this stuff.
I mean, how--
I'm just reading it.
"I liked you more when you were
fat and balding."
>> I was never fat.
>> "I wouldn't [bleep] you
if my dick was on fire
and your ass was
a bucket of water."
>> I can't imagine what that
would smell like.
Just old dick burning?
Ew.
>> Oh, no.
"You're not only autistic,
but you are a [bleep].
I hope you get a dick tumor
I will murder your family,
you [bleep]."
>> You kiss your old, old
sailor buddies with that mouth?
>> I don't have any old sailor
buddies, and I don't know
what you're talking about.
"You look like Jared Leto
in Dallas Buyers Club
but gayer and with more AIDS".
"Do you prefer to eat dicks
by the bagful or bowlful?"
>> Bag.
>> "You have feminine hips."
>> It's the wrong Comedy Central
star.
I have zero body issues.
>> Okay.
"I just hope you can find
a noose made of cashmere."
>> That's pretty funny, I guess.
>> "I thought roasting queers
was a thing of the past."
"Daniel Tosh looks like
a [bleep] Jared from Subway
had a [bleep] baby
with [bleep] Jim Harbaugh."
>> Jesus.
>> That was a stinker.
But I didn't, uh,
write this, you know.
"What is it like to use Twitter
when you're 40?"
>> I don't know.
What was the Civil War like,
you crusty [bleep]?
>> Hey. Wait a minute.
"Tosh, you were born
in Germany?
That explains why you have
germs a many."
[chuckles]
>> I get it.
>> Oh, you do.
>> Don't stare at me like that.
>> Well, I didn't write this.
>> Uh...
>> I wouldn't write something
this stupid.
>> [laughs]
>> "I hope your next
starring role
is in an ISIS video."
[chuckles]
>> Do you think that's funny?
>> I do.
"You're dope.
Seen you at your taping
a few weeks back.
You're genuine nice and funny."
>> [bleep] you.
It'll be Old Lee's turn to
get roasted soon,
and then I'll flush his ashes
down my toilet.